if I had been doing it for the money was
a grifter and I remember this moment
when I became aware that my thoughts and
opinions were different than most of my
peers and I was like oh it's a choice I
their need to just be honest or I can
I'm smart enough to be able to just pair
it the talking points and be like
reporter you know is it Larry Bird and
that's hilarious when they say that over
in retweets that would be grifting from
for me that would be a grift
this is the Reuben report and according
to the deep state i'm dave rubin quick
reminder guys subscribe to our youtube
channel which gives you just a teeny
tiny chance of actually seeing our
videos all right then joining me today
is a writer a comedian and host of the
dumpster fire right here on YouTube
Bridgette fat Izzie welcome back to the
Reuben report back all right lady you're
back Oh still here last time I had you
on here you were at the the beginnings
of your political evolution you were
saying I don't know what's going on with
this world you're trying to make some
sense of the world I still have no idea
well a year later or whatever then
barely a year earlier barely a year
you're one of you know you're on the
short list of people that make some
sense to me so what does that say about
me hey that's terrifying people say this
to me and I'm like you know that that
the world has gone crazy of somehow I'm
a voice of reason and I get a lot of so
I guess what's happened is it's true it
has been kind of an exponential
I guess just from like a statistical
point of view and numbers point of view
I'm something like Twitter it has been
exponential rise our growth yeah and
with that comes a lot of criticism and
every good criticism people saying mean
things to you on socially
I know it's strange I I know that this
doesn't affect other people but it
really seems to affect me predict you
know but I feel like the criticism I get
all the time is I'm a grifter you know
like I'm some like I was one way and
then now I'm another way grifton but
yeah you know eventually you're gonna
need to knock off this both sides
routine yards because you're always
trying and just I'm like I'm just being
me though I'm really just confused yeah
do you think that that's sort of what's
working for you more than anything else
like there's enough well there's just an
upfront Ness about your evolution like
for me something like five years ago I
just started saying it guys I'm a
liberal but something ain't right around
here and then it was just people started
going
oh me too and I I sense you're sort of
like just constantly in that people
thank you but I think the difference
between us is that you are already kind
of in the political world yeah and what
was your degree in political science
okay so yeah you wanna three people that
ever use the political science in
college I dropped out so a lot of pot
yeah but I was blacked out and smoking a
lot of pot and waitressing and I say
this to people at that I you know I
talked about the factory settings and
how I think when you're just when you
have your head down and I didn't know
until maybe a cup maybe last February
how I was gonna pay more than two months
worth of bills
ever since when I was 17 so when you
have your head down just trying to
figure that stuff out you're not really
paying attention to the anything else
yeah I was just trying to make money and
wait tables and I moved to LA so that I
could be a content creator I wanted to
write television shows and do comedy and
I didn't I was never I was not aware
there was a culture war going on which
sounds completely naive of me and
Michael Mouse has said to me you know
that just goes to show you how how how
entrenched the cathedral is in terms of
media
and entertainment and academia is that I
didn't even know I was in the Cathedral
right do you sense that getting the
criticism of grifter somehow you're
doing this for money even though as you
said it's just literally a year and a
half ago or you're like you know
scrounging around all that and also you
know it's it's also funny because people
think just because like we're on YouTube
we have a little powder in our faces
that we're like rolling and dough and
it's like I'm not complaining by any
stretch and it was a long time to get
here you know you mean I want it and I'm
just somewhere on my journey as you are
yeah but I find that this thing of like
because a lot of people in our space now
get thrown with grifter or you're doing
it for the money or your cell or
something like that
and in a weird way while that used to
bother me now it's becoming in in some
ways it's the ultimate compliment
because it's almost like they have
nothing left right like there's nothing
left about the ideas that you put forth
or the positions that because you hold
you actually hold a lot of mixed bag of
sort of left-right positions which I
think most people do yeah so all they
got is actually doing it for the money
money as if you were like oh if I just
stuck out that position over there you
know that's where the money rules if I
had been doing it for the money was a
grifter and I remember this moment when
I became aware that my thoughts and
opinions were different than most of my
peers and I was like oh it's a choice I
there need to just be honest or I can
I'm smart enough to be able to just pair
it the talking points and be like
reporter burn that's hilarious when they
say that over retweets that would be
grifting from for me that would be a
grift because for my idea of a grift is
that I'm not be I'm being disingenuous
I'm being dishonest I'm saying that I
have one thing and I'm selling another
but I'm selling my if I'm selling
anything it's my confusion wouldn't a
grift also be that you would you would
take the easier way out like you would
like clearly I think I think the people
that are in the space that we're in
whatever you want to call that like this
is the road less travel right but like
if you're on the grift you don't do the
hard thing you do the
easy thing yeah it would be easy for me
to go in either direction all in it
would also be easy for me to completely
just deep defect and be like I'm agonize
and I always joke that there are these
two strains of Trump derangement
syndrome and I can quit it like pretty
quickly tell if somebody has one or the
other it's if everything is Trump's
fault or Trump can do no wrong and it's
maghen resistance so it's like the
hashtags and they are and I feel like
most people exist in the gray area in
between but they they get so bombarded
by both sides if they dare to be like
well I think there might be you know I
can see this from both sides there there
might be a perspective here that they
just saw like now I'm not I'm just gonna
be quiet so speaking of that it's a good
reason to have you are now because I
know you're an expert in foreign policy
especially especially related to Iran
right that's your specific expertise I'm
here know that obviously is not true but
actually often in the morning when I
wake up and I having my coffee and I'm
just sort of like slowly getting online
and I'm trying to get my thoughts Center
well I'll shoot you some tacks and go
back and forth a little bit and one of
the things over the last couple weeks
that like consistently comes up is like
the craziness related to every single
person on Twitter but I don't want to
make this just about Twitter but like
the need for all the celebrities all of
the journalists yeah well you know
air-quote journalists and just everybody
to have yeah to have a opinion on
everything at all times remember I mean
right we were in world wars they were so
bad at World War three go for you about
well I walk my dog that's a crazy thing
and and we kind of talked about this on
dumpster fire my youtube show which just
makes fun of it my whole thing with
dumpster fires like we just want to
laugh while the world burns because in
the moment when news is breaking and
having it is diplomacy by Twitter
now so there there is serious you know
our there's news breaking the
president's tweeting a flag than the
ambassador to the Supreme Leader's
tweeting their flat these are I mean my
room
Samantha Sutter perfectly she said it's
Enders game meets wrist cutter perfect
description yeah and I think that there
so there is this real people are getting
hurt people are affected by this it's
all playing out virtually and then you
close your computer to put your phone
down and walk outside and it's like dude
did it to do right
nothing's going on and the majority of
people have no idea they're not like
living in that but if you're in that
moment in the news cycle is it's all
breaking and everybody's got their takes
and the journalists are all trying to
figure it out and they're waiting for
the Pentagon to confirm things so that
they can confirm the rumors there it's
you get that kind of rush what do you
make of these people that literally
something happens now and then they have
the exact opposite reaction because it
was another administration five years
ago I'm not talking about somebody
that's evolved over time with their
political ideas right I'm talking about
well Trump didn't have congressional
authorization and then there's literally
five years ago their tweet when they
were completely for Libya I mean Nancy
Pelosi is a great example Trump didn't
need I don't even mean just the people
in politics yeah but there's a video
right now that's been going around that
I've shared of Pelosi five years ago or
whatever it is six years ago saying
Trump didn't Obama didn't need
congressional authorization we toppled
Yanbian regime in Qaddafi now he needs
it like but then everyone just flips on
every little thing because it's all it's
all sports so my question is has it
always been like this and we're just
more aware of it because everything
lives forever because what about ism is
gonna destroy their estate yeah because
you can always say well what about this
and what about that and what about this
and well actually and go everybody can
go back and forth but what are your
principles I guess and and it's so easy
to to just adjust your mind to confirm
your own belief in principles
anyways that I don't know how anyone
really avoids being a hypocrite and
politics and maybe it was always like
this and we're just more aware of it
yeah one of the things that I find which
is why I think you're a sort of a breath
of fresh air in this is that a you're
not pretending to be an expert in all
[Music]
someone will now clip Oh Dave Rubin says
the bridge of a disease in Iran but
you're not putting an answer but also
like you are being funny throughout the
day and it's like we really have watched
comedy gets slaughtered yeah it's a
freaking thing it's weird because you're
so I just got told that dumpster fires
being shadow banned I don't know if this
is true or not so you saw somebody
tweeted at you that basically there
subscribe to your channel a bunch of
people they're subscribed to your
channel my video didn't show up in their
feed and I don't Bridget I I'm shocked
and appalled that you matter I just went
on YouTube like three months ago you're
over the target sister what's happening
well we make a lot of inappropriate
jokes and I'm you know we were joking on
this week's I'm like Maggie was say no
who's gonna want to sponsor this show
because I said something like I was
joking about how the Golden Globes went
vegan and I was like I just missed the
good old days right you know a man could
be a man and a woman who's in the
kitchen Maggie's you can't make even
jokes like that because someone will
clip that and then say see here is
Bridget with her internalized patriarchy
unless you say that everyone from the
1950s was a racist bigoted homophobe
you're cancelled I yeah but is it should
we just pre canceled because comedy is I
think saying those you know I said
something that was really it's always
those off-the-cuff jokes you make that
are completely inappropriate that I
think I said something about cardi B and
we were filming and the dumpster fire
which and and I said you know she said
threatened to go to Nigeria and I said I
was like I have fun with Boko Haram and
oh yeah
and Sam who are in there filming with me
right my cousin Maggie who's my
producing partner and Samantha who's
also on the team they started dying
laughing because it's that's what's
funny is those things that are
off-the-cuff and if you say something
like that now and you aren't in a
position like I'm in which is I slightly
immune to cancel culture you will get
canceled or your own risk of getting
cancelled so I think comedy has become a
lot more afraid and then you know the
argument that people say is like cancel
culture isn't real is that people like
Ricky Gervais and Dave Chappelle are
making jokes well they're millionaires
yes they're multi and they're powerful
so you're just you can't use people who
or even JK Rowling you can't use
billionaires and multimillionaires as
examples of people who are who are
cancel proof because they're cancel
proof just because you're rich do you
sense though that people like us maybe a
if Gervaise and Chappell let's say
you're doing it at like the Air Force
level right that were sort of more the
foot soldiers in this or something like
or we're in the tanks on the ground and
we're offering cover to the average
person that is the foot soldier in this
that just wants to be able to work a
real job but still occasionally say what
they think without being mobbed and
where we are actually offering them a
little bit of cover yeah yeah I think
that people what people feel confused
and there is that sense of terror
that's but also hilarious and we were
talking about this as well and dumpster
fire just how it's you're you're it's
almost like a defense fumer for me as a
defense mechanism it is for many people
and that's why inappropriate jokes are
funny because you're like haha
World War three right guys and then the
memes come out and the memes are
hilarious and so people are using humor
to try and make sense of a world that's
really crazy and then you have all these
people who are experts and I always say
no one knows anything I mean even
experts they might know things about
they might have things to contribute but
no one knows what's gonna happen
so anyone who's telling you like here's
what's gonna happen
is really just projecting their own
biases and hopes into the world but no
one is like Nostradamus an argument so I
think people just want to laugh to make
sense of it you mentioned your factory
settings yeah which I have credited you
with many gems 99% sure I credited you
when I mentioned it in the book I
suddenly as I'm saying it I suddenly
afraid that I didn't but I'm but let it
be known that you were the first person
that came up with the phrase factory
settings that I had ever heard can you
just explain what factory settings are I
know we talked about it last time but
but I think it's such a right way of
sort of looking at at why everything is
so screwed up or or sort of how you
would take everything down to first
principles to then sort of look at the
world yeah factory settings is really
just the default that you were kind of
installed as a child for instance I was
raised in a very liberal family it was
very East Coast we I didn't I was
thinking about the other day I'm like I
don't think I even met anyone who was
pro-life until I was yeah maybe I just
was not exposed to I didn't I I was in
Minnesota but we lived in the city so I
was always very much and and again I
wasn't really you know engaging in the
debate club at school so I didn't I had
some conservatives in my life but my
default settings factory settings were
just you know
pro-choice Republicans are evil all they
care about is money
you you're the good you're the good guys
Democrats are nice poor people yeah do
you think so do you think that's a
personal thing or that generally that
when I when I've used the phrase maybe
this is my own take on it I've sort of
said to people that the factory settings
that were all given pretty much if you
grow up in America or you know in the
last 40 years let's say is that that is
the narrative so yes of course some
people are brought up say Christian
conservatives that brought up pro-life
or whatever but that's really a that's
really an outlier
right okay the main set of ideas that
are sort of accepted out of the gate
which are Democrats good Republicans bad
Democrats for poor people Republicans
for rich people Democrats you know all
of that kind of well it just depends on
where you grow up because I think
everyone's factory settings are
different and that and it depends on
your region so if I was raise them you
know somewhere in the South perhaps or
in Texas or in a different family then
perhaps I would have different factory
settings my very good friend is was
raised conservative and he was raised to
think all liberals are idiots and that
they you know can't can't argue any of
their own points they they so he that he
just won't even really engage in the
leftist debate because he he thinks that
that was the way he was raised by his
family that was conservative but it was
also known that they were not the
mainstream point of view or right that
set of ideas wasn't writing coming down
to you from Hollywood and the media all
the time right and to kind of keep those
ideas somewhat on the down-low
so even in graduate school he had to
he's had to kind of pretend just fake go
along with a lot of the crazy stuff that
he's seen and just because he wants to
kind of swim through and get done and
and be done with it but so I think there
that's interesting too I don't know
i I've been it's been interesting
hearing from as many conservatives as I
have in the past couple years their own
struggles at colleges and how they're
kind of these you know they're outliers
really in the culture and I didn't I
never knew that because I was just like
whatever let's back up for a second
though because that
relative to all this for people that
that don't know you or didn't see our
first interview you're a former addict
yeah I think in a lot of ways seems to
set up sort of your view on all of this
that this isn't that the culture warfare
as important as it is right and this is
what we do every day and and I do
believe that this fight is the fight for
Western values and all of these things
like it is important but that you've
already lived through like your own
existential battle for existence right I
feel like that you know I grew up in a
kind of crazy household too so I think
there are a lot of people probably like
me who grew up in dysfunctional homes
where the culture as its gotten
increasingly more crazy I'm like that
meme a little you know dog drinking
coffee like this is fine while
everything's under fire because that was
what I was used to so the culture is
finally reflecting like I totally caught
up to this functional home but I I think
the existential crisis the first time I
had it was 19 you know let's be clear
I'm still an addict I was making you
retired so that's still there I can do
anything addictively even if it's good
for me and I have a I do have like a
crazy you know I get fixated on things
and obsessed with them Twitter is a
great example I have a hard time people
always like how do I get on Twitter what
do I do
I don't know what to tell them because I
love Twitter myself away yeah so I but
you take some breaks too
I do and I have a my I have a pretty
healthy relationship to social media for
the most part but I find it's about to
get healthier we're going to talk about
yeah my my I think what being in
recovery has done for me during all of
this craziness and I have I just
celebrated six years of sobriety in
October it I can't personally be an
anger or resentment because it puts
my sobriety in danger so I can't live
with that stuff so I quickly have to
figure out how to come into acceptance
and I think some of the biggest problems
and I'm sure this existed with
conservatives when Obama was president I
just never saw it because Walker's
factory settings for the draw as Michael
has explained it that cognitive
dissonance but in particularly on the
left and this is what's really so
fascinating to me psychologically is
trying to align those things of watching
people applaud dictatorships and regimes
applied things like the economy crashing
so that little more of a person can be
correct is I'm really unsettling to me
because that is you are willing to see
people suffer to validate your own
rightness like come on getting yourself
reflected all can't you look at yourself
and see that you're cheering for the
supreme leader so that you can be right
where how is there and then I'll read
these you know psychological studies
about how people it feels better for
people to have their beliefs validated
no matter what those beliefs are then to
bend to be challenged and and we see
crazy crazy examples of this like this
is not just something you're saying as
if oh these are random Twitter people
doing it I mean a couple of them are
Bill Maher literally said it would be
great if the economy crashed so that
Trump would get out and it's like well
it's pretty easy for you to say you know
guy that probably is worth a hundred
million that's one thing but then be
friendly the other one the other one
though a couple weeks ago on the view
when Joy Behar oh yeah so the Joy Behar
says a bit of good news white
nationalist Richard Spencer is no longer
supporting Donald Trump regret
supporting Donald Trump because of the
urine strike and
and the audience cheers yeah which meant
that they were cheering that the white
nationalist no longer supports Trump as
if Trump is worse than the white nation'
we made fun of this on dumpster fire I
was like the audience is like yay okay
the white nationalist agrees with us
Trump is a bad man yeah I'm like what
how can you sit and that is what is I
think for most Americans I believe I
still hold onto the faith that most
Americans are looking at all of us and
going like what the you know yeah you
act you to say what the [ __ ] didn't that
feel they it's just and there's
craziness all around it's not just on
one side or another it does feel chaotic
everywhere and but that in particular
kind of back that cognitive dissonance
is is really just and you can see there
a link there between that and something
that you went through with addiction
like I need to like keep doubling down
no man or something like like you're
always rationalizing your existing thing
I can't I don't trust myself being in at
being an addict made me not trust my
thoughts and so and I tell this to
people about reading the news I you have
to be aware of your own biases I'm very
aware of my own biases I'm very aware
and they're probably something I'm not
aware of but I'm as much as I can be
aware of them and I'm aware of my
defects and my addictions and my
weaknesses and in order to get sober you
really have to take in Mike instance I
had to take a very hard look at all of
that and it would be very easy for me to
justify just going I could have easily
said because I wasn't going into the
election some huge Trump fan I could
have easily the night that he was
elected said I'm gonna drink you know
like I can't live like this and I can't
I don't have that luxury I because that
I will probably die or end up in a bad
state and I quickly and this is what I'm
saying is that the thing that's lacking
when you have cognitive
acceptance generally being able to
accept what is and so much of that
craziness on on the left right now
because I'm sure it was true with the
right with Obama but right now because
there they lost they cannot accept that
he won they just cannot accept it still
have you found any tricks you know
people ask me all the time while Dave
you seem to have made a little headway
with some of these people right like
helping like the struggling lefties
understand really what liberalism or is
or whatever but as someone that comes
from a similar place in that regard have
you found any tricks to break these
people I mean I guess comedy is really
the one comedy persistent to know so
what I think my sense is that there is
there's anyone right of Bernie and then
the people left of Bernie I guess and I
think once you're once you're in the
hashtag resistance Trump derangement
syndrome whatever you want to call it
that strain the only way you have an
epiphany is when you get cancelled grow
so when the mob inevitably comes for you
which it will that then suddenly you'll
see these people coming and asking for
my help or advice or like oh my gosh I
didn't see this because so much of my
personal awakening was when I was saying
things out of lockstep you know first
it's like well why am i self censoring
okay well stop stop censoring you
quickly realized why you're self
censoring when you start just saying
your thing yeah and once your own tribe
kind of turns on you and comes for you
well you start questioning that tribe so
I know you don't consider yourself on
the right or certainly not a Republican
or a conservative or something like that
but are you always shocked still so this
movie might follow up to our
conversation a year ago where I was sort
of like I kind of know where you're
gonna be in a year or something like
that are you kind of like boy these
conservatives and libertarians at least
right now are just pretty nice like do
you ever get [ __ ] from them really there
that's been
interesting to see they're more willing
to engage in conversations I always joke
that you know I I think I'd joke Tevan
the last time I was here
but I've started doing stand-up about it
is you know I the factory settings I
always thought I was liberal and then
they tell you when you get sober that
you won't be recognized and I'm like how
much weed was I smoked yeah I'm a
conservative now and then conservatives
will start talking about porn and oh my
god thank god
I'm not with you guys all right cuz the
minute they start talking about like
porn and stuff oh my god now when are
you either yeah thank God wait let's
talk about that thing so there was a few
weeks ago there was this thing was it
Matt Walsh she was the guy that so Matt
Walsh who's a daily wire guy yeah yeah
so he put up a post just clean this up
or you want to get it
maybe he basically said something to the
effect of that porn should be illegal
and that we should jail pornography
later in the threat I think he said that
to somebody who was like let me be clear
so we should jail the pornographers and
the people who make it like yes
absolutely
okay so now he's a conservative he works
at the Daily wire I know you like Ben
and I like Ben so let's this isn't about
the daily life it's not a bit about Matt
specifically but it sparked like a four
or five day war on Twitter but it was
really it was intellectually really
interesting because it really did show
the difference between conservatives and
libertarians right we're libertarians
it's it's always about the maximum
amount of personal freedom right that's
the part that I usually decide to I lean
towards and then for conservatives it's
about conserving some traditions that
over time seem to build a healthy in
their minds build a healthy society with
some sort of traditional values my my
real belief would be that classical
liberalism is the fusion of but what did
you make of that whole debate cuz you
you got into it a lot I did get it I sat
it out every now to get him like I'm
gonna sit what I was gonna set it out
and then I it's hard for me to sit it
out coming from Playboy and posting new
tea it being me it's how I'm like your
boobs are on the Internet my boobs are
on the internet are for me to sit that
one out so we just lost 90 percent of
the people watching this because they
just went to find hey yeah come back
that that's interesting that was the
reason that I kind of waded into it and
I I don't even know if I can
I just think again one of the factory
settings that I was taught was that
that's the I grew up with the party of
Family Values you know the conservative
Family Values and then there were cracks
in that that's not what you grew up in
but that's what you know that they
believe and witnessing you know it was
like all about the moral majority and
those were the years that I kind of came
I remember hearing snippets about that
and we are Gen Xers old-timers we are
youtubers God were dinosaurs
we heard dinosaurs we're pretty much
like one ten years away from getting
okay boomer and I just so I grew up with
that impression that they were the ones
who were very much about the traditional
family and and then you know you started
seeing the cracks with the evangelicals
and a lot of the the controversies and
the scandals that came out of that and
then and then with Trump being elected
in his history I I'm like mmm you guys
don't really get to make that argument
you can't defend Trump as your president
on principle and also say porn is
destroying America right I'm sorry
that's the cognitive dissonance that you
guys have to deal with and so I did wait
into it because to me it just feels like
you're you're like a very pro Trump and
people can say well I can separate I can
separate his actions from his from his
you know his private life or whatever
but these are the same people are
screaming at Bill Clinton so no you
can't right so so as someone that that
used to write for Playboy someone that
does have their their boobs out there do
you like the word boobs what should I be
is not boobs are the W speeds
[Music]
but for someone that okay your boobs are
on the internet you've written for a
playboy so you know this this world yeah
what would you say so I saw a lot of the
arguments the anti-porn arguments that I
saw were that it is fundamentally just
destroying we can remove the viewer for
a second right people that are in it the
amount of them that become drug addicts
that are eighteen years old and just
need any money so all kinds of things
like do you find any of that argument
compelling or anything there I and again
I'll say and I said this when I was
talking about the the porn the porn
online the porn on the internet
as someone who wrote for Playboy and had
my dm's open before I couldn't leave
them open anymore I had thousands of
emails for men who were talking about
their struggle with porn so putting it
aside putting the argument that porn I
see it as a substance so in the same way
that I mean I had a porn addiction for a
hot minute and it was when I was trying
to quit all the other things I think I
just replaced there with porn and and it
is I do think that it desensitizes you
in a certain way and it does make you
numb it does make it does make things
more confusing and I with it with the
opposite sex or the same sex or whomever
you're having sex with now in this state
is like whatever I don't care
so that is one argument but I don't I
would treat it the same way that I would
treat alcohol and weed and I have a more
libertarian view on it that that is not
for the government to regulate because
the argument the Conservatives were
making is that the government should
come in yeah and regulate this and and
make it go you know ban it essentially
and I don't I don't I don't share that
that's the solution I think that just
pushes things underground it makes it
more dangerous for people in the
industry and it makes it more enticing
for people because now it's the thing
that's not allowed right it also strikes
me that why that argument feels kind of
thin where maybe
years ago or 20 years ago it would have
felt bigger is that 20 20 or 30 years
ago like VHS tapes you want to get into
porn you probably had to work force you
know you to work for a studio right or
what you to move out to the valley but
but you probably were in more of like an
institution where the opportunities were
there for people who abused you where
now it's like there are people that make
good jillion dollars literally just
sitting in their bedroom with a webcam
with no middleman it's just it's just a
direct interaction with somebody else
right so it almost feels like it's a
little cleaner or something I don't know
if that's all fully true obviously I'm
not an actual economics of porn but like
something something to that maybe well
and it's the you know well because then
you start wading into the idea of sex
work so you're talking about if you're
talking about people who are making it
whether are you a cam girl are you
something like for your shows or but
what's let's back up a girl yeah are we
going to arrest the cam girl the II
thought you know every girl that shows
our butt on Instagram we thought yeah
what is it
it's like a E - th ot yeah and thought
is that hoe over there
oh it's internet slang but sorry I've
been accused of being II thought but I'm
an e thought that was sent I mean this
is the stuff I get from the right-wing
yeah is that I'm a deep state plant sent
to undermine the conservative party I
guess because of conservative ink you
know ben shapiro and the far i can't
stand these like tolerant conservatives
that the irony just real quick on that
though i that to me shows you what's why
something good has happened with the
conservatives because when the far-right
elements start attacking them now they
go on the attack where on the left when
the far left elements attack they seem
to always move towards them now they
sort of bow to them where on the right
when when people have attacked Shapiro
and charlie Kirk and people that I would
say are more mainstream conservative
they actually fight back and they say no
you if you want a white nationalist
state you're you're the bad guy you're
the one that's counter to America
we're the left seems to always be if the
if the bad guys out here they always
follow him out there yeah and I don't
even I'm not sure if it's um you know
the I guess bad guys it's it's that what
is the horizontal yeah Joy Behar
ultimate lefty suddenly on the same side
as Richards bender you know Spencer
far-right he boom I get emails I got one
the other day it said this is a fight
for you know you sitting on both sides
while the fight for America and it was
like this tirade against me and how you
know no one's gonna remember anyone who
laughed while the world burned or
something and I was like well lucky for
you I don't want to be remember that but
I could not tell you who it was from
I couldn't tell me for us from the far
laughter the far right yeah and I posted
and even if it was a good it was it was
nice to see my followers were a little
mixed on this too because I posted what
it said and somebody was everybody was
like that's obviously from the right
that's obviously from the left that's so
whatever you believe is the way you
perceive that - yeah and it's just it's
a little bit it's bananas being your
when you are kind of in that space
you're like whoa what it is a mirror it
somebody the other day on Twitter said
that the American flag should be the
spider-man pointing at the other
spider-man yet not yeah yeah yeah that's
funny alright let's shift a little bit
here because let's talk about big tech
because you've got an interesting
announcement I did come in but just
relative to the whole big tech
conversation and as someone that you now
you might be shadow band yeah you can't
and we don't know if they're gonna get
us and shadow banning as I keep
endlessly repeating is now quite
literally in the Twitter Terms of
Service if you are an American it
doesn't apply to the Europeans for some
reason but if you're an American it is
now in the Terms of Service on Twitter
that they can throttle who sees your
tweets on top of that I just saw as of
the day we're taping this today that
they're gonna they're considering
doing a tip thing on Twitter yes but
think how dangerous that means yeah
that's an interesting idea
but now they're also saying they can
throttle you but then that means they
can also not just control who whose
information gets out there but who can
actually make money
- seriously - interesting all that being
said when it comes to big tech as
someone that's in this as a creator and
a youtuber and Twitter and a boob person
and all that stuff
where are you on regulation and what we
should do about this this thing that's
obviously pretty intimate so to you I
had to think a lot about this and I was
always that was one area it just
intersects with a lot of my interests as
big tech free-speech oh my god this is
gonna be real interesting in the future
and we'll see how well that holds up
because free markets big tech and free
speech often do not you know get along
very well because they have an interest
- they're obviously to their investors
and then you have things happening on
patreon like the actual financial
backing is like MasterCard kind of
putting the pressure on to boot people
and now there are so many different
topics but I don't believe everyone has
a right to a platform so I just I I
don't think that everyone has a right to
free speech in America in the places
where you are allowed to have free
speech that doesn't mean that appointing
the public square
meaning the public square now that
doesn't mean that a private company owes
you a microphone yeah so what about the
people that say but but Twitter and
Facebook and YouTube are avenues we
communicate and if they're if you're not
allowed on there it's like saying to
somebody thirty years ago you can't get
a telephone in your house you know
what's interesting to me is that it's
generally people on the Left who are
saying this or on the right who are
getting kind of throttled but on the
left it's like get them all off
Manimal it's not the public square but I
think that what it hurts really
marginalized people with a mode of
course they trickle down and so I don't
know it to not consider at the public
square is dangerous in some ways because
then you are really it's like
but it's the it's just so crazy it's
just but it goes to show how you're not
gay because you don't think the right
way
someone is kin isn't black if they don't
think the right way it's the ideology so
if you have the right ideology you'll be
allowed in the public square well that's
not the public square but it is weird
with Facebook in all these places
because as far as I'm concerned just
being that they're private companies
even if they were smart enough to create
a public square they still get to do
what they want to do yeah I mean I I
don't know what else to say about that
that's just that sucks the best line I
heard on this and this was in the middle
of me trying to figure out how I wanted
to fight this battle was everyone always
says but this time they have so much
power that it's different so the idea
would be that this time you libertarians
you kind of have to you have to put it
aside and let the government do it
because this is because Google is so
much information so much hard this is
the time and then you're on Brooke we've
had on who have you chatted with your
own you you should definitely have him
on from 9 Rand Institute basically I
mean it's the most simple thing but he
said it's so plainly as if it was
nothing that it really destruct me he's
like well if you wouldn't have
principles when they're the hardest time
to have those principles that you don't
really have them right and so he's
completely against regulation so that
leads me to why over the last year and I
just announced it barely a month ago I
started locals come to allow creators to
own everything that they're doing own
all your content own all of your user
data set whatever rules you want in your
locals we started mine which we have
about 10,000 people in there now at
Rubin report.com and we got an iOS app
and a Google Play amazing but I'm not
pimping myself out here Bridgette
because this all leads to that you this
is the first time it's being said
publicly you are the first creator on
locals people can go to feds e.com today
pH ETS a one-way tanzy pH et a sy yeah
yeah is that what I said yeah no you
look at sa why it's fine
dyslexia there put it on the screen but
you are the firt you are the first
creator beyond me that is on locals comm
and we're super psyched to have you
there and we had literally about 5,000
people that reached out that within that
first couple weeks to create communities
and I was like Bridget's the right one
because you are just in the center of
all of this I'm excited because well
there's a couple many reasons one you
put your money where your mouth is you
know a lot of that a lot of people when
I was I was too small to really I was
affected by people like Jordan and you
and Sam leaving patreon because you took
a lot of people who who subscribed me no
I had my own friends angry at me that
were like if you left that it's okay but
but people cancel their patreon accounts
because of us so then a lot of you guys
it's fine whatever and again I don't I
really don't like to be the you know the
victim II thing so even I'm like alright
shadow band me alright whatever I'll
figure out a way because I always have
you actually did figure out a way and
made something and a lot of people are
like we'll go make your own internet
like okay fine I will go make my own you
know Platt it's a platform though is it
well it's it's a it's an on platform
Plataea it's a creator specific platter
different I'm one of the cool things
that we're going to be launching over
the next couple of months now that we're
adding some creators and you're just the
first of a whole bunch of them that
we're gonna add is that we're gonna be
able to connect our communities so
they're able to connect your community
with like-minded people yeah so perhaps
if Dave and Bridgette like each other
will connect our communities it'll it'll
strengthen our feeds and our fans will
be able to communicate with each other
and if one day you're like that Dave
Reubens real [ __ ] you'll just
disconnect the connection and that's it
and the idea was let's give all of the
power back to the creators and make sure
that the day that the day that you say
something on dumpster fire that
YouTube's like we're done with this girl
well guess what you don't have any of I
mean think of how many subscribers you
have on YouTube ballpark
oh I mean I've only been on for like
three months so
11,000 about great the day that they
find you too much of a threat or
whatever and hopefully by the end of a
show we're gonna send some subscribers
your way but but the point is that you
have no way of communicating with those
eleven thousand people they've chosen to
smack you gentle but you can't get your
message out to them because the
algorithm sits between you and getting a
message yes yeah yeah this gets out of
wish I wish I had my phone on me you get
actual push notifications on your phone
so I think we've built something pretty
cool no it's very happy that you're part
of it I'm so excited I'm excited I I was
telling David that I cried when I saw
David yes that I cried when I saw just
the that because it's just fantasy so I
started I made up the word fallacy years
ago because and it means when reality
becomes parody now in 2006 this didn't
mean anything and now it's like the
culture has kind of caught up to the
word and then because social media was
so new I used that as my social media
name because they I didn't really trust
social media knew nothing about it and I
didn't and I wanted to get the word out
well I inadvertently became the brand
before my company did because my company
went bankrupt because I was 27 and
didn't have a business plan I was gonna
make greeting cards again trying to just
be a voice from people I felt like
didn't have a voice which was like
divorced people and people who had kids
out of wedlock and and that's where I
started and then and then it took on a
whole other life of its own which is a
crazy journey and probably the book I
should write because it's been and then
I sigh you know just fantasy back with
the original logo and I'm like we we I
never gave up on this I have it on my
phone it's only it's the test version
but yeah and fantasy was always meant to
be
a content creation that's all I want I
wanted to be a production company and to
I like I said I mean I have scripted
podcasts I want to make I have
locals-only content that I want to put
on and and I see locals now are the
fantasy locals as my hub where I get to
do that and just keep expanding and
collecting people as long as I
aloud in the public forum yeah but it's
the home I mean what I'm trying to tell
me was it's it's your digital home yeah
you do whatever you want you know you
can't you know our TOS our Terms of
Service you can't break the laws of the
United States across the board on locals
but beyond that one of the cool things
is you set the rules in your local yeah
I set the rules in my local so if
someone's just being purely evil in mine
I just don't want your money and goodbye
you're out you may have a different
policy related to what you know what
you're real pretty much yeah and my
that's what I wrote in a kind of funny
way it's like it's not that I have three
strikes it's just like don't be a
relentless dick and if yeah if you just
can't do that then I don't want I don't
I don't want your money yeah I mean
that's how I feel it I call it my gated
community well the new institutions are
being built what do you think though
because we're doing this as a
subscription thing about that maybe the
day of the absolutely free internet
being the main driving force of
everything is kind of done because
that's sort of what I'm feeling like yes
I get it I'm not leaving YouTube or
Twitter any of those things for
discovery for you though but well they
just stole your soul yeah like Twitter
takes your soul and all your information
so one of the things I love about yours
is that I take that stuff I mean I am
nuts I have no interest in selling
information people give me to third
parties none yep
I don't like it when other places do
that to me I have no interest in that if
I shut down and die it all dies with me
that's also very clearly written for my
partners like I don't want them taking
it and selling it and I just I I think
that the you know I was saying as I was
watching all of the past couple of years
the debates and the siloing of public
and private opinion is happening anyway
and I was saying everyone's gonna end up
going back to their domain names and
everybody left their domain names to go
into these you know social media places
and now everyone's gonna start kind of
reverting back to those place they're
their homes their home pages do you
think that that's part of the problem
and a way to link them all and be social
so it's the few it's the future it's
amazing we I'm psyched about Owens
amazing
when I saw when you guys showed me that
demo I was like that I got in the car
with cousin Maggie really this is the
future cuz it's social media meets you
know content creation
it's like patreon meets Twitter a little
bit yeah and it's Scrolls and it's sexy
it's just I'm so excited well it's also
like I wanted to you know people
everyone that comes in this my house and
everyone that comes in here I always
repeat the story but like Tucker Carlson
who's the number one guy in cable news
who probably makes fifteen million
dollars a year or something insane he
literally opened up the door to my
garage and he's I don't know if you
would want me fully saying what he said
but he said he basically said holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah right yeah meaning I'm
free i building and I feel like I've now
done enough to now give the tools yeah
to some other people to do those things
and if you leave locals congratulations
it's all your data we don't keep it we
keep the at handle just in case someone
wants to stay on another local but yeah
we don't keep that data you can go yeah
whatever you want with it and all that
good yeah it's exciting it's exciting
and I think it's I just love the it's in
line with my principles of free speech
and free markets and being an
independent content creator and I do
think like you were saying that the
future I mean right now it's subscriber
and my kind of entry level might be a
little bit higher than I'd like just
because I that's for my own ability but
I I think the few wouldn't you mean your
your tier my entry level to locals is
five bucks no I'd like to get to the
point where so many millions of people
know about me that it's two bucks and
they get all this cool content but
because it because there's just more
awareness and so because I think the
future probably is people finding those
creators that they like and spending you
know their money instead of on a cable
package which is a total read yeah
you're paying 180 bucks for literally
182 channels that you don't want yeah
maybe for live sports which again
they're all going you can watch those on
Twitter um you can pay two bucks to
somebody like me and three bucks to
someone else
and you have your little media budget
for that kind of content what do you
think about just generally like that
people we thought that social media and
all of this stuff was gonna bring us
community but what it brought like it
helped a lot of us succeed right like so
we're living examples of the good part
yeah but that would it also brought was
a certain amount of endless anxiety and
the sky is falling and everything's
horrible and everyone hates each other
and you said it before but then you can
close your computer and it's fine and
that's what I wanted to bridge that was
the divide I wanted to bridge between
like the good stuff that's online yeah
and then also figure out some real world
stuff so like I was in San Francisco I
would never tweet where I am because God
knows who's gonna show up but I did put
it on my local no IDs are paying people
and about 20 people showed up within a
half-hour in San Francisco all that
drinks and it was awesome and it was
like oh that's right you kind of have to
like make it cost prohibitive to keep
the riffraff
yeah there's no perfect system right
there's no perfect system because
someone might pay it to do oh yeah they
might but then it's up to you then
either you take their money or you just
or you don't well it's up to you you
make a good point about the the
community one of the things I've seen I
fostered a kind of community and patreon
and when I was going through hard times
this year which where there were a
couple the community showed up for me in
a way and I watched them show up for
each other when somebody said they were
depressed and you know they felt safe in
that community because there weren't all
of these onlookers and I have been
introducing people like so many people I
joke that my my podcast should be called
all my friends are from Twitter because
I've made so many friends and been
exposed to so many ideas and and I have
my ideas challenge and I I don't think
that I see so much good in it and I feel
so grateful to live in America I feel I
just some kind and again this is a
lateral cut really it's it's also just I
wake up I'm like I'm so lucky I'm just I
feel very lucky for the most part and I
do want to help other people and I see
how
everyone's going so leading into the
election and then whatever happens
post-election
I really want my local community to feel
like they can challenge each other push
back have reasonable conversations and
not be me not person no personal attacks
but also support each other and their
goals for the for the future their goals
for one of the people who's in my
community he's like a brilliant
businessman he's been mentoring other
people in my community it's just so
wonderful to see well by the way we
should give a shout-out to our man
Warren oh yeah last name but Warren pro
idea yeah so Warren from Xen pro audio
yes he owns his own audio company Warren
was one of my first supporters I mean
years and years and years ago he's
amazing for in all of my know you know
this but all of my audio stuff the labs
that were wearing all of the
soundproofing I donated all of on top of
being the supporter for years and he's a
big supporter feel like I really we
should give him a little shout output
but related to to community and all that
do you think that what people will say
oh but Dave you're gonna you're gonna
just silo yours right inside you're
gonna save space you know I was thinking
about this on the way over because that
is what's happening anyway so I believe
right as if the people saying it and I
go out of my way to challenge myself so
automatically if I read something and it
confirms my bias whatever that might be
or if I feel that like ha I'm dubious of
it you know I'm suspicious of it now
this comes a from not trusting myself
really and my own thoughts and beliefs
from kind of being an addict but be I
think it's just good to train yourself
to know what your biases are and know
that when you're being flattered you
should be suspicious this is also just
like a Zen thing and - it's our
responsibility you know somebody we had
this discussion the other day and it was
a really good question someone in an
audience said where do you get your news
what is your trusted news source well
people ask me this all the time of what
I always say is you can't you already
said this actually the beginning
interview but you can't trust
institutions anymore you can basically
figure out a couple people to trust so
there are some journalists but even
journalists I don't even know what they
are anymore there's some personalities
that I basically think are good faith
actors okay
who I think are worth following but
there's very few I just saw literally
right before we started that you know
Lee Lessig who is the he was gonna run
as an independent a couple years ago
just run on campaign finance reform and
then he said he's a tech guy and and he
was gonna sell fund his campaign he
ended up not going anywhere with it but
I just saw that he's he's suing the New
York Times for for libel because they
wrote this ridiculous hit piece on him
and then I looked at the byline of who
he's suing and it's the same author who
wrote the hit piece about enforcement
agha me on Jordan Peterson and who wrote
the ridiculous piece last week on Prager
you that they're circumventing parents
and teachers what was the point of that
why was I telling you that related to
all of this there was some reason there
and I completely lost it in the midst of
that Oh trusted news source right that
you can't trust any you can't just say
oh the New York Times is good because my
dad used to like it when it was good
right and obviously this I'm no fan of
this particular author write her name
about it but that's what you can't just
trust the institution anymore but that's
not to say that there isn't a good egg
at the New York Times right not quite
sure who it is but there's got to be no
they did still do some amazing
journalism and I don't like what that is
I'm sure but isn't that some ways the
suckier part right when they do
something good because they do so much
bad now that then they do something good
and that your ability to or delivery
it's only hear about the bad because I
think journalists you know I don't I
don't I definitely don't want to
demonize journalists in the mainstream
media or journalists journalists and
journalism I feel like is very important
to democracy and so why I demonize the
bad ones yes because they're journalists
as I like to say it's like they're
activists posing as journalists which is
dangerous to democracy also dangerous to
democracy is calling every single
journalist an enemy of the people
so we finding good-faith actors is
increasingly harder and I also think
somewhere in be you know I read
everything I try to read left right
center libertarian just because I feel
like somewhere in there I can form my
own opinion and I've become like a
psycho about okay I'll read this
headline went to my gut instinct that's
interesting read the article
oh that quotes completely thinking out
of context alright let's read the study
Oh
who made the study but I have time to do
that yeah most people don't have time
nor the even desire they just see the
headline it confirms what they believe
and they're like yeah so we got put
warrior II on you Noa cuz I feel that
too is that like because life seems to
be getting faster at the digital age is
making information consumption faster
people are living in worlds where you
get your food delivered at the same time
it yeah this and you're watching this
and editor and you're on your peloton
and you're doing with that woman's doing
and the whole thing that in a way the
job of the curator right if that's what
we are in a certain way like we're sort
of in a world of like these relatively
trusted people our job is more important
or not I don't see more point it's yes
it's highly important relative to people
being able to make some sense out of the
madness yeah that that's a new pressure
that I I'm not an expert but I
definitely think I also don't just get
to say I'm a nobody and don't know
anything because it's not really because
Katie my responsibility and also and I'm
and it's I'm not an expert I'm I only
have my confusion offer that doesn't
mean I don't have any knowledge and it
doesn't mean I don't have any insight
and it doesn't mean I just get to be
like but also all the self percent
professed experts often get everything
wrong yeah all the time yeah so I like
people who do and you're gonna make some
mistakes along the way I mean in a weird
way this is like Trump's greatest gift
it's not that he's he's he's certainly
no expert in politics I guess he could
be an expert maybe in building you know
building buildings physical structures
something like that but he's an he's not
an expert in politics but he has a gut
feel for something that seemingly is
sort of right in a certain way or
whatever wherever you want to put that
in many ways I get him no to it I
understand the way he kind of shoots off
the hip and it's like he's very
intuitive for sure he's and people would
say you're like an intuitive political
pundit you are like an intuitive pundit
where I don't know anything but I do
have a good general sense of I don't
know like the way thing the current or
the site geyser what that is a real
thing that that is a real thing right
like I always say I always tweet this
thing about how is it possible that
Trump this orange-haired you know giant
bloviating seeming buffoon is more of a
real person than the Democratic
candidates and then you see elizabeth
warren dancing up there
yeah that's people are so desperate for
authenticity that they'll pick an
authentic [ __ ] over disingenuous you
know yeah lifetime politicians who have
been paid by the government forever yeah
and so they don't there's just a
distrust of all our institutions so I
think anyone who's being authentic is
somebody that people are like well I can
trust that person now that might not
also be zero as well and I was saying to
the the other day of my I had someone
call and they're like how can you be
both sides and the family member and she
was distraught and crying and like can't
you see the kids in cages and you know
they're like repetitive things that I
often hear online and you mean the
system that Obama set up that nobody
said anything about it yeah yeah that
system and this is what I said I said
the hardest thing about this time is is
evaluating what was
with every administration that is now
being demonized because it's Trump and
what is something that he's doing
completely differently that we need to
be aware of and push back against and
this is where I will say principled
conservatives are have been pretty good
and there are some who are very
consistent some of the never Trump errs
or whatever who are lifetime
conservatives they might not always be
right but if you know you kind of have
to find those people really like okay
this is a left-wing thing who are the
people who push back against left-wing
and what's their take on it and what's
the never Trump pers take on this is
this a thing that's always been
happening or is this a thing that is
something that you know we should be
concerned about you know it's funny
though I find the never Trump er is just
big even that phrase I would never want
to be defined by what I never am again
but it's such a horrible way to define
yourself
it also shows why so many of them have
seen one crazy intellectual dark web
well IDW has a nice ring to it but the
idea that you'd say I've never told well
that's a real dangerous thing because if
he does six out of ten good things and
you're up never Trump well now you're
wrong six out of ten times yeah you're
failing so I know and I don't I don't
know that a lot of people who get thrown
in that camp even consider themselves
never Trump er yeah it's kind of it
everybody just wants the B label you
know i I'd I always just get called
Rubin to point out that's like
everyone's like remember over three
years ago she's gonna be saying the same
thing in two years I'm like well I have
to be the leader of the alright yeah
that would be pretty good I will be
pretty good
all right Bridget we are gonna send
people to feta Singh Kham it is the
first local that exists beyond the Rubin
report logo and I'm super psyched that
you're doing it and you're gonna be big
we have a good community you know
there's a lot of people in recovery
there's like a lot of people who aren't
it's just mostly very loving people who
are confused and and it's really
interesting there's so many you know I
have it's just so interesting the
different kinds of people that I feel I
do feel like if I am in a gated
community in a silo at least there's
still dialog occurring it's not just all
one thing or all the other things
there's still a lot of talk in my silo
weight and more important than anything
else I hope that you're sharing pictures
of hope your dog in there my mind's very
Emma heavy and we both are so Emma
most of my audience knows at 15 and a
half and a year into cancer were sort of
entering that that last phase with her
but I've actually I've posted some
questions about geriatric dogs and
palliative care and I get incredible
responses from people about all that
kind of stuff and hope was going through
some stuff with her but she's okay right
yeah she's okay
yeah so you just find strange ways to
build community yeah and I think that I
do believe and I love people you know I
think that most people left right center
wherever they are are doing I think they
they're they believe what they're saying
you know I don't know doesn't mean
they're right he doesn't mean their
logic is bad I just think I try to give
people the benefit of the doubt because
I know that it's you know it's hard
being human give Bridget the benefit of
the doubt at fantasy comm if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about comedy instead of
the nonstop yelling you get everywhere
else check out our comedy playlist and
if you want to watch full interviews on
a variety of topics check out our full
episode playlist they're both right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell